[Music]
[Applause]
hey thanks for full housing with me guys
I really appreciate it you're welcome
I wasn't talking to you so you're gonna
keep your end of the bargain right one
more full house top five the top five
full house moments people really want to
see you got it dude the top 5 best
Michelle moments we can't let this
happen it had to be done yep these are
the top five worst episodes of full
house number five
back to school blues from season three
its DJ's first day of school and boy is
it exciting going to junior high for the
first time could be intimidating
it's the oldest of the Tanner girls
finds out she's heavily embarrassed by
upperclassmen and even goes to school
wearing the same outfit as a teacher
oh no if that wasn't thrilling enough
for you Joey tries to teach Jesse how
the golf in the backyard
do we know I only went to school
together for the past six years Kathy
Santoni Kathy Santoni big-time what they
don't recognize so um they've grown up
with because she grew boobs these people
fashion seems to be a big deal in this
episode in addition to DJ dressing like
her teacher Jesse comes out in like
yes hilarious because that is a much
worse look than this my personal
favorite part of the episode is when
Aunt Becky teaches DJ about makeup
the secret to wearing makeup is to make
it look like you're not wearing any how
do you do that yeah how do you do that
well by bringing out DJ's natural beauty
for instance you want a very subtle pink
eyeshadow riveting number four
Tanner's Island from season three what's
worse than the Tanners in San Francisco
the Tanner's in Hawaii
the full house gang flies to Hawaii for
a vacation and hijinks and Sue's after
over-scheduling their trip Danny
accidentally leads them to what they
think is a deserted island
they argue a lot and eventually end up
singing and dancing on stage because
full house the only thing that's missing
from this episode is an airline
commercial Northwest Airlines with a
proud new look was pleased to provide
travel to Hawaii for full house
Northwest Airlines to more than two
hundred cities in 21 countries oh ok
times up everybody out of the pool
you guys haha Joey is constantly seeing
a hula girl throughout the entirety of
the episode much like this sentence it
goes nowhere
[Music]
[Applause]
haven't seen one sign of intelligent
life neither have i Jesse after being
thought lost for a decent amount of time
the episode ends with the whole crew
singing an Elvis song in front of a
large crowd look at those moves number
three our very first telethon from
season three this episode is only 23
minutes but it sure does feel like a 24
hour telethon Danny is hosting the we
love our children telethon to raise a
million dollars for the Children's
Health Center he wants everything to be
perfect but plenty of things go wrong
including him doing his best impression
of the audience and falling asleep
during the show Oh Danny you mind-reader
you this episode has it all
comedy a magic routine a peach boy
cheerleaders how could it go wrong very
easily
[Music]
I've rarely seen anyone's that
uncomfortable singing a song I know one
of the Olsen twins is right in front of
you but at least try not acting
terrified my favorite guy in any band is
always the bass player you know because
the bass player is getting into this
thing doo doo doo doo doo
and he looks already sees the rest of
guys in the band and he smiles write it
out I agree please cut it out
we've had enough one of the Beach Boys
also just shows up towards the end of
the episode
they're like full House's version of the
Eagles in the Lord of the Rings whenever
something's bombing they throw a few out
there to try and save the day
[Music]
[Applause]
number two secret admirer
from season four this episode is just
one big kooky misunderstanding danny is
dating a woman named Cindy who has an
obnoxious son named rusty rusty writes a
fake love letter to DJ from The Paperboy
who she has a crush on the letter is
accidentally passed around the house
from person to person until everyone
thinks they're in love with each other
then they all have a picnic just one big
cookie zany wacky it seemed like at this
point in the show they tried to add the
troublemaker
rusty as that extra character no one
wants in a sitcom
but even full house knew this was too
much and he only appeared a few times
sorry mom was a long car ride okay I'm
going
so after rusty writes the love notice
the paper boy DJ likes he gives it to
Michelle who gives it to Stephanie
Stephanie thinks it's too her and is
grossed out Cindy then gets the note and
thinks it's from Joey from there ends up
in the hands of Becky who thinks it's
from Danny then it moves on to Kimmy who
thinks it's from Jesse Jesse finds the
note in Becky's pocket and thinks either
Danny or joy gave it to her DJ thinks
rusty gave Stephanie the note and tries
to let him down gently
but she's interrupted leaving rusty
thinking DJ is in love with him Joey
then thinks Becky is in love with him
when she confides in him that she thinks
Danny wrote her the letter boy this New
Kids on the Block Cologne really works
Becky then confessed Danny and gives him
the letter which makes Danny think
Becky's in love with him Cindy then
confronts Joey which makes him think
she's in love with and Joey gifts love
the note gifts toilet paper a coffee pot
mom number one worst episode of fall
houses the return of Graham from season
1 I think the title speaks for itself
when Danny's mother comes to visit she
sees that things aren't working out as
well as expected with a sportscaster a
comedian and a mullet raising three
little girls she brings in the others
mothers to get things back on track but
the three stooges don't want them there
so they have to do what they can to
change their mommy's minds and blah blah
blah blah this show sucks the return of
Grandma is about as bland as it gets the
only thing out of the ordinary in this
episode is that Jessie brings home a
turtle named Bubba that he thinks saved
his life I love this amphibian
he loves that amphibian it's a reptile
okay the joke isn't funny it's a
frigging reptile just when you think you
couldn't get any worse we get a cleaning
montage
like sugar spice
[Music]
why did we watch the show America why
did we watch this why it's been going on
and on for 30 years and people still
watch it and now it has sequel series on
Netflix that people are apparently
watching it's already three seasons end
is possible why are we slaves to the
Tanner family can someone please explain
this to me for the love of God we have
to do better I'm sorry I refuse to
believe that humanity is this stupid
everywhere you look my face will be in
your face if I see you watching this
show when you're lost out there and
you're all alone I'll be there to take
you dumb for watching full house it's
just natural selection its mother nature
will take care of it by well you happy I
won't destroy you all none of you will
be like standing we want to hear what
you guys think yeah what's your least
favorite episode of full house leave a
comment and let us know now if you'll
excuse us we have to go throw up for
talked about the show for some damn long
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
you